outra briga que vai acontecer direto
porque sempre um trabalha mais do que
outro não adianta alguém vai trabalhar
mais do que alguém arsu vem secar a
louça tô culpado Man chama o indus é
iso tem que secar lça tin um ódio de
secar louça tão grande com raiva tenho
tanta raiva de secar eu prefiro lavar eu
prefiro lavar que é digno Você limpa
você lava aquela corisa bonita secar
Ninguém pede para secar você fal deixa
eu secar lça não secar é o que lhe
restou tipo assim vai seu bosta tu não
sabe fazer nada pelo menos enxuga essa
louça roupa combinando só quem tem irmão
veste roupa combina a mãe compra um
tecido faz roupa para todos os filhos
vão tudo igual Parece uma boneca da
Larissa Manuela e o povo mangando ó o
chck Teco e as roupas tudo igual aí o
meu irmão era maior que eu quando eu
crescia eu usava a roupa dele par ser
que eu usava a mesma roupa a vida
inteira só mudava de tamanho a roupa